alors vous êtes l'occupant de la maison
qui se trouve juste à côté
effectivement qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il ya eu un glissement d'éboulement est
ce qu'elle est tombée hier à trois
reprises entendu du bruit je me suis dit
bon je vais pas y arriver pour garder sa
matinée au vote
mais ce calme aux sons du moment la
route ça s'est passé dans la nuit alors
oui ça c'est du d'après vous à quoi ou
dernière puis il y avait beaucoup de
zéros sort là parce que c'est grâce à ça
faisait déjà depuis quelques temps on
avait averti on a eu aucune y est passé
l'atr l'escalier sont bien en fait qu'on
vous dise avait déjà commencé depuis
quelques temps c'est à dire le sol
s'effondrait déjà pas de chaque jour y
avait deux pieds aux deux pieds au de
piau et au final on arrive à ce que les
dégâts sont conséquents ou c'est juste
les mouvements est arrivée juste au pied
de la maison
mais arrivés au pied de la maison
seulement pressez pas sur les côtés on
n'a pas accès
mais il semblerait que le chemin aussi
soient rendus inaccessibles à l'échangé
déjà parce cela at il ya des gens qui
sont passés mais c'est vraiment pas
solides ou à faire tout ça
et ça fait combien de temps que vous
alerter la municipalité sur les risques
d'éboulement déjà au moins quatre mois